integrative oncology is that aspect of
oncology that is concerned with the
totality of factors that are important
both in the prevention and the treatment
of cancer and those include conventional
forms of therapy everything from
chemotherapy to radiation therapy to
bone marrow transplants to monoclonal
antibodies to targeted therapies all
those things it's also very concerned
with screening and early detection and
it's also concerned with all the
nutritional factors that we know are
important not only for preventing cancer
and associated with risk reduction of
cancer but also in the treatment of
cancer and it's very important for
people to be concerned about their
immune systems and their detoxification
systems so both those are part of
integrative oncology as well and there
are two scientific branches that are
very important now to integrative
oncology one is called nutritional
genomics nutritional genomics is the
interaction of nutrients with the genes
that can turn on or off cancer with the
genes that are responsible for the
production of our detoxifying enzymes
those are our first line of defense
against many of the environmental toxins
were all exposed to in the air and our
food and our water those type of things
and also there's a field called toxic Oh
genomics toxic Oh genomics is how all
the different toxins in the environment
from dioxin to DDT to dde to PCBs many
of the things that are held in our body
for decades and fatty tissue many of
these affect our DNA as well and so
they're almost competing
scientific realms where nutritional
genomics is looking at what can be done
to benefit our health and the toxic o
genomics looking at all the things that
we know compromised our help and so all
these are very important the other big
part of integrative oncology is stress
reduction because we know there are two
really new fields that are incorporated
into integrative oncology one is called
psychoneuroimmunology the other is
called neuro cardiology
psychoneuroimmunology is the study of
how stress depression pessimism all
those negative emotions literally
depress every aspect of our immune
system there was a fascinating study out
of Ohio State several years ago
published in the Journal of the National
Cancer Institute and what that study did
was look at women who are recovering
from breast cancer surgery they found
that women with the most depression and
stress had the most profound suppression
of the very part of their immune systems
that we know is very responsible for
preventing a recurrence of the cancer so
we know equally that positive emotions
optimism peacefulness those type of
emotions upregulate every aspect of the
immune system so it's very important
both for prevention and even if you have
the disease to look at how stress
affects you how old traumas and patterns
affect you so that's a very very
important part of your own cardiology
the other point that I'll just get back
to that I mentioned is neuro cardiology
neuro cardiology is about the link
between the brain and the heart and
there's all these neurologic pathways
between our brains in our heart and the
reason that's important is when we're
stressed one of the first things that
happens is our breathing changes it
becomes very shallow second thing that
happens as our heart rhythms in what's
known as heart rate variability so it's
not your heart rate per se but how much
your heart rate is changing second to
second minute to minute your heart rate
variability increases its high when
you're under stress so your breathing
becomes shallow your heart rate
variability increases that sends signals
to the brain that then put the brain
wave in a corresponding type of pattern
and the whole stress response starts
your cortisol level goes up your ACTH
level goes up that induces cortisol we
know that depresses the immune system it
interferes with your digestion increases
your heart rate increases your blood
pressure by the same token when you're
very relaxed if you're doing meditation
guided imagery cheek on any type of
meditative practice yoga all those kinds
of things they actually will decrease
heart rate variability so it's the
opposite of the stress response it's the
relaxation response there's a lot of
data showing how that will increase
every aspect of the immune system so I
wrote a book in 2001 called the healing
power of sound where I talked about how
every spiritual practice on earth from
the beginning of time has used music and
sound and breathing and chanting those
types of things and it doesn't matter
what the practice is they could be the
Sanskrit chants from yoga they could be
a chance from the Kabbalah they could be
Gregorian chants that are sung at
Vespers they could be Native American
healing chance tibetan buddhist chants
they all have the same fundamental
homes and rhythms and they all induce
the relaxation response in part by
causing your breathing to be more full
your oxygenation to be better your heart
rate variability is slow and that
corresponds with the induction of what
are known as alpha and theta and delta
waves in the brain those are the most
relaxed brainwave patterns when you're
in those patterns your brain releases a
different set of chemicals throughout
your body so what happens your heart
rate goes down your blood pressure goes
down your cortisol level goes down your
immune function goes up so there's a lot
of data to support even though many
things like yogurt thousands and
thousands of years old we're just now
coming to a real understanding of how
profound physiologically these things
are so integrative oncology is really a
basket that holds all these different
modalities from you know the best of
Western science to really the most
esoteric of the eastern practices